[Music]
so I'm gonna talk about the fact that
migration I think generally has the
potential to be a force for good with
many benefits but that it's important
that we know that there is a two-tier
system in operation both in terms of how
we conceptualize it and how we
experience it and ignoring that is not
helping us it's also not helping us if
we ignore the Gulf of understanding and
experience because that has already had
a consequence in the referendum results
but will have a consequence for the
future I'm also going to say that the
solutions to this Gulf lies in more in
tackling underlying inequalities
economic inequalities but also social
inequalities that are both intra and
international and that if we don't close
that gap and focus instead on lecturing
people with whom we do not agree that
they are wrong and we are right we will
not get very far and here we are not
getting very far and I'm also going to
talk about the fact that we haven't had
the sort of national debate that I'm
gonna try and do a mini version of today
with one exception which again I'll talk
a bit about so first of all who moves
well probably everyone in this room
maybe I don't know I won't make you put
up your hands but I think a lot of
people in this room may have had some
positive experiences of migration
perhaps of work purposes perhaps for
studying purposes or perhaps you still
intend to but probably most of us were
not forced and probably we had
relatively few difficulties in then
returning when we wanted to or moving on
but war climate change and extreme
poverty forced many other millions of
people to migrate each year with much
less choice we then have family members
trying to join relatives and people who
are not the world's poorest but
nevertheless want to move to a different
country because they believe they can
achieve a better life for their families
by taking another job in that family and
sending home their salary in the form of
remittances and I'm going to talk a bit
about that I'm gonna give you a few
figures I tried to keep them to a few
but first of all about international
migration as a whole and these are
figures correct up to the end of 2017
and that showed that since the year 2000
international migration as a whole had
been growing at between 2 and 3% each
year since the turn of the millennium
reaching 250
million migrants in 2017 258 million
that's up from 173 million in the year
2000 most of these people are in
high-income countries
high-income countries host almost
two-thirds of in all international
migrants about a third 92 million are in
middle or low income countries and of
those most are in the middle-income
countries and also most of the world's
migrants as a whole live in a relatively
small number of countries and in 2017
more than half were living in just ten
countries the largest number were
residing in the United States of America
50 million that's 19 percent with Saudi
Arabia Germany and the Russian
Federation holding the second third and
fourth largest number of migrants
worldwide and I was surprised actually
by that that some of that um followed by
the United Kingdom with nearly nine
million and the United Arab Emirates
with 8 million and of the 20 largest
countries of destination of
international migrants worldwide nine
are in Asia seven are in Europe tour in
Northern America and one each in
Africana and Oceania and then thinking
about the country of origin of those
international migrants 106 million were
born in Asia 61 million were born in
Europe the second-largest region of
origin so Europe is part of the source
of international migration and the
destination I'm relatively few migrants
are born in North and America only four
million or Oceania so relative to their
share of the world's population and
migrants from Europe Latin America
Caribbean and Oceania are
overrepresented while international
migrants from Asia northern American
Africa are underrepresented forced
migration however is a different picture
so forced migration people who did not
choose to move but felt forced usually
by war sometimes by climate change or
extreme poverty by the end of 2016 there
around sixty eight point five million
people who are forcibly displaced that's
about a quarter of all international
migrants so that may be the opposite way
around from a lot of the popular
discourse most international migrants
are voluntary most are effectively
economic migrants though the governor of
the Bank of England doesn't tend to get
called an economic migrant in the
economic migrant he is nonetheless
the developing regions hosted eighty-two
point five percent of the world's
refugees and asylum seekers so there's
another myth I think I hope Scotch to
most refugees and asylum seekers I only
go to the first country they get to for
all sorts of perfectly obvious reasons
once you think about it
but that also means that countries such
as Jordan the Palestinian territories
Lebanon Pakistan and Pakistan and Uganda
Uganda are the host countries for most
refugees and I think if we want to take
a different approach to immigration we
need to think about what the the last
President of the United States President
Obama started in the global compacts on
migration and refugees which aimed not
far succeeded to share out the
responsibility for migration and for
Refugees more equitably around the world
because at the moment we basically leave
it to the neighboring countries the
frontline States millions of people were
displaced during the foot each of the
last few years fleeing war and violence
and so on as well as from Syria which is
one of the largest countries of origin
of refugees
that's Syria there were five million
Afghanistan 2.6 million in South Sudan
2.4 million those are the top three
sources of refugees but refugees also
come from the Central African Republic
the DRC Iraq and Myanmar and at the same
time other protracted crises remain in
trench so the war in Afghanistan
actually technically was over some time
ago but refugees are still arriving and
2 million of them are still hosted in
the Islamic Republic's of Iran and
Pakistan hundreds of thousands more
across the world so people move mostly
they're not forced is that a good thing
for the sharing of ideas of skills of
experiences the broadening of minds you
could say yes for the providing of
sanctuary you would say yes although
that's not quite the same thing because
most of those people probably didn't
want to move before they were forced to
but what about social cohesion what
about a sense of identity what about
climate change
what about family life and it's less
clear when we consider all of those
things that migration is just simply a
good thing which many of us would have
started out with
I haven't mentioned for instance
internally displaced people people often
think about refugees but actually half
of the people displaced by the war in
Syria are still stuck in Syria about
five million and they're stuck for all
sorts of reasons that partly to do with
border controls on the the southernmost
States above them so the northern states
above them so what about a migration
from the EU and the impact of the
apparently impending departure from the
EU and here I want to draw attention to
another two-tier aspect which is that
almost from day one and it was literally
I think about week later after the
referendum I as an MP was lobbied by a
very well organized very articulate
group of EU 27 citizens they were mostly
the academics the doctors the
environmental consultants professional
people with very high sense of their
entitlement their correct
entitlement to be there but also an
expectation that they would Lobby me and
I would be able to deliver what they
wanted or at least that I would support
it which of course I did but this is a
concert in contrast with virtually zero
lobbying by those EU 27 Inu 27 citizens
from the new member states from Eastern
Europe anecdotally people are telling me
that those who work in the care sector
or are the margins of employment and who
come from the new member states have
they've not just not lobbied me they've
gone home quietly without any fuss now
doesn't mean they were happy about it it
means they had no expectation that
lobbying me would produce any results
whatsoever whereas the University
lectures and so on have either stayed
and continued to lobby me and fight or
they have taken equivalent jobs
elsewhere in the EU so this is another
two-tier a two-tier of people who have
some agency and choice and people who
have less agency and choice some of us
who love free movement and voted to keep
it and have loudly campaigned to keep it
and we say it's a good thing but what if
we were to extend that good thing what
if we were to extrav and restrict it or
end it what would it look like if it
went worldwide what would a globally
open border system actually look like
and there may be some of you in the room
who believe that that's the way we
should go we should have completely open
borders well if we did I would say we
would still
have a two-tier system it certainly
would make it a lot easier for people
like me to move where I fancied moving
it would mean less admin but probably
two places that I would probably have
gone to eventually anyway um and that I
would continue to treat the world as the
place that I believed it to be a place
that was open to me but there would
still be forced migration they would
still be people forced to move because
of conflict and poverty and climate
change and they would still be making
dangerous journeys the inequalities
would still exist and people who had
economic means would find it easier to
get out of war and conflict relatively
speaking than those who had less what
difference would it make
open borders make and I think for the
millions who remain displaced within
their own country such as the Syrian
internally displaced persons their lives
would possibly be easier because they'd
be able to get through the Turkish
border more easily however they may
still be trapped by the nature of
conflict so it's not a simple solution
just saying let's get rid of all the
rules as people moved we'd still have
forms we'd still have processes we'd
still have registration and
deregistration and Taxation and we'd
still have rent agreements to sign so
there would never be in my view a system
with no sort of administration behind it
and therefore if there's administration
there would be rules and if there were
rules there could still be people who
were out with those rules and therefore
people who would be eventually than
asked to leave or sent home for more
debates talks and interviews subscribe
today to the Institute of Arts and ideas
at IAI TV
you